well we've been talking a lot about face
masks and whether or not they
are going to be worn in secondary
schools in england uh
has the government committed a u-turn
joe pike joins us live from westminster
what do you know joe
well they seem to have changed their
policy possibly called a u-turn jane
certainly boris johnson has now
dropped advice against using masks in
school
so young people can wear masks of course
this is mainly focused on corridors and
communal areas
but masks we're told will be mandatory
in english schools when they are in a
local lockdown area such as
greater manchester the message from
government today is when the guidance
and the science changes
their advice change they are being
flexible as they need to be
in a global pandemic but clearly england
moving to a similar or
not exactly at the same position as
scotland announced today we know whales
are considering this
and tonight northern ireland also
intimated that from next week
they will be recommending masks are used
by pupils
in schools as i say though jane this is
only in communal areas and corridors
where social distancing
is not possible but significant i think
that boris johnson and the uk government
are changing the advice for english
school children
and of course that will come into effect
for most of them next tuesday
thanks very much